I mean that is just ridiculous
fili cocoa keeping it really real on the
gram we told her that Lori is an angel
sent from heaven who helps my body as my
hips and legs hurt 24/7 The Big Bang
Theory star took her followers along for
a little holistic health care experience
I am absolutely wrecked I don't even
know how to function right now
there was cupping explain what horrific
things you're doing to me and a whole
lot of intense exfoliation she's just
scraping at me yeah the whole thing just
seemed kind of painful the 33 year old
said she hit the gym before the intense
treatment which she called bodywork guys
I've got to do more of I
I mean I go a few weeks and I end up not
being able to walk no Keeley didn't
explain why she's unable to walk but she
did share this my body just starts to
shut down from just complete overuse and
if I can't if I don't take care of it
like I'm gonna crumble you gotta take
care of yourself in order to be able to
take care of the things around you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]